thank you all for coming my name is
Marco Cusimano towner and I work at MIT
in the probabilistic computing project
so today I'm going to be talking to you
about some new programming constructs
for probabilistic AI that we've been
developing in our group so suppose
you're given some data like the image on
the left and you're asked to explain it
one explanation is that this is an image
of a coffee mug but there are lots of
other explanations you could give at
different levels of detail for example
you could say that this mug is being
viewed from the top so in the right the
red icon shows the viewpoint of the
camera relative to the mug and this more
detailed explanation could be a lot more
useful than just saying that it's a mug
for example of for robot we could plan
the sequence of grasping motions we need
to do in order to grasp the handle now
we could also give other explanations
for example we could say it's an empty
mug or we could say it's a ceramic mug
or a white mug and lots of different
ways of explaining this image but for
now I'm going to suppose that we're most
interested in the 3d geometry of the mug
and it's 3d orientation relative to the
viewer so here's another image of the
same mug so what's the 3d orientation
this time well in this case there's two
plausible explanations instead of one
it's definitely being viewed from the
side and the handle is visible but it
could either be standing upright or it
could be upside down and both situations
would have resulted in the observed
image on the left so a key feature of
human common-sense reasoning and
probabilistic reasoning is the ability
to consider multiple plausible
explanations for the data and in other
words it can be uncertain about things
and uncertainty is going to be a key
recurring theme in this talk so here's
one more image of this mug how would we
explain this one
well here we probably have even more
uncertainty so like in the previous
image this mug could either be right
side up or upside down but because the
handle is blocked we don't exactly know
what angle the mug is at this time
so there's a continuum of different of
different possibilities so if we didn't
assume this was a mug beforehand
actually there's even more explanations
we could give for example maybe it's
some sort of how cylinder shaped object
or maybe it's just a cup without a
handle or maybe it's a solid cylinder of
some sort so the set of possible
explanations that we're willing to
consider is one of the key types of
assumptions that we bring to the problem
and we might also assume that some types
of objects are more likely than others
right so maybe hollow cylinders and
strange solid cylinders are less likely
in your environment than mugs and and
cups so if you see this image maybe
you're more likely to think it's a mug
or Cup than a strange hollow cylinder so
these are all examples of probabilistic
inference which I can which we can think
of as generating plausible explanations
of observed data so I'm going to show
you another example suppose we're in
some environment that contains three
trees and a walled enclosure with a
doorway in it now suppose we see a
person moving around in this environment
so on the right each blue X is going to
be the location of the person at some
time point so here they're starting at
the bottom left at zero seconds and
after one second they moved up a little
bit and after ten seconds they're
located here next to the wall
so we want to explain this observed data
so we have to make some assumptions so
first we're going to assume that they're
trying to go somewhere and at the place
they're trying to go is somewhere in
this environment so we have can also
suppose that they know the environment
pretty well so they're able to plan an
efficient route before they start
walking so then the person's destination
and their planned route is going to be
our explanation so our question now is
well where in the environment is this
person trying to go so here are going to
be a few possible explanations they
could just be going right where they
look like they're headed so the red dot
is their destination and the gray line
is their route they could be going a
little further that's also a good
explanation or they could be going
inside this enclosure that also makes
sense
and they could be going anywhere inside
the enclosure really or they could be
going across to the other side of this
this area so what makes these
destinations more plausible and more
reasonable than the other points like
this one well we it's based on our
assumption that the person is trying to
be pretty efficient in their walking so
we're gonna judge security's routes like
this one to be less likely so the image
on the right now shows an aggregation of
all these possible destinations that
could explain this data and again this
is an example of uncertainty we can't be
exactly sure where they're going but we
think that some areas are more likely
than others so lots of other problems
can be framed this way so for example if
we see a sentence I see a man with a
telescope you know it's two possible
meanings at least one could be using a
telescope I see a man or I see a man who
has a telescope and these correspond to
two different parse trees for the
sentence and we can also use
probabilistic inference for more
standard statistical problems like
interpreting some time series data so
here we see some data on the left and we
might say well I think this is a
sinusoidal oscillation with some fixed
period and there's also a super linear
trend and maybe there's something some
pattern going on in the troughs of this
sinusoid but I can't be 100% sure that
that's real could it be some noise so in
each of these examples there's some data
and then there are assumptions that are
going to bring to the problem and one of
the key assumptions is the type of
explanations we're willing to consider
in the first place and once we've done
this inference process and come up with
our explanations those may be of
intrinsic interest for example like I
said we can use the orientation of the
mug to plan a grasp but these
explanations can also be useful
indirectly because they allow us to make
more accurate predictions of future data
so on the Left if we've infer their
destination maybe we can actually
predict their future motion in the
middle if we've figured out what the
patterns are underlying this data maybe
we can actually make forecasts and on
the right if we figured out how the mug
is oriented in 3d space we can predict
the image we would see if we moved our
camera up a little bit so to solve
problems like this we're
use probabilistic programming which is a
relatively new programming paradigm and
associated set of software tools and
this paradigm draws on Bayesian
probabilistic inference techniques which
have been one of the core computational
tools for solving problems in lots of
areas for years including Natural
Sciences like astrophysics ecology and
genetics and lots of technology areas
including robotics genomics and my
natural language processing and these
also have been one of the primary
modeling techniques for understanding
human cognition computationally
so although Bayesian probabilistic
inference is a very powerful tool it's
been notoriously difficult to use
because it requires a lot of specialized
knowledge of probability theory and
numerical programming so one of the
goals of the Provost at computing
project and probablistic programming as
a field as a whole is to make Bayesian
probabilistic inference techniques a lot
more usable and accessible to a broader
audience by developing new software
tools and new abstractions that hide
some of this complexity from the user so
here's one one key idea in this new
paradigm so in traditional approaches to
Bayesian inference the assumptions are
expressed in some mathematical notation
maybe in the purse maybe in the users
head or on some pen and paper and then
they derive a custom algorithm for this
particular problem to trying to solve
and then they implement that algorithm
in C or R or MATLAB in our probabilistic
programming paradigm we're going to
declare our prior assumptions explicitly
by writing code and that code is going
to be a simulator that generates all the
situations that were able to possibly
imagine before we see any data then
we're gonna write inference procedures
that and we're going to use with the
help of probabilistic programming
systems and I'll show Jen is one
published aquarium system we're going to
use in this talk and these systems
provide tools for analyzing the
simulator code and doing various
different types of execution of that
code so let's see an example so this is
the inference problem we saw before and
we're trying to figure out where this
person
going so our first task is to write a
simple stochastic simulator for a
virtual world and a virtual person who's
going to be walking around in this world
so I'm gonna write this simulator in
Julia so what are all our assumptions
well the first assumption is that the
environment or the scene is some fixed
thing and that we know it so we can
assume there are three trees and an
enclosure then we assume we know the
PERT where the person is starting so in
this case they're starting in a lower
left-hand corner represented as a black
dot now we can we're going to simulate
the person's destination but the
destination is something we don't
actually know so it wouldn't make sense
to pick any deterministic value so to
express the fact we don't know something
we're gonna use randomness and we're
gonna pick a random point somewhere in
this scene to be the destination and
that's in red so each time we run the
simulator we're gonna get a different
destination now we're going to simulate
the route that the person it's going to
take to their destination and remember
our assumption whether the person is
going to take efficient routes so we're
gonna use a route planning algorithm to
generate this route and this function
plan route takes the scene the start
point and the destination and generates
a pretty efficient route that avoids
obstacles so the routes we get are just
a sequence of straight-line segments in
this case and next we're gonna simulate
the actual location of the person over
time and that's going to be the blue X's
so we could have just simulated points
along this route by just walking along
the line and that would give us these
orange X's however no one really wants
in exactly straight lines so and we
don't want to assume anything about how
a particular person walks that would be
an unreasonable assumption so again
we're gonna use randomness to express
the fact that we don't know something
and here we're going to rat add random
noise to each of these orange Nexus to
get these blue X's which is the actual
person's location and finally we're
going to return this simulated virtual
world which includes the scene the route
and they start in destination so there's
a bunch of other assumptions in this
code I didn't mention and it can be fun
to look through code like this to find
what
are but one pretty easy one to find is
that the speed is fixed so that's not
necessarily reasonable and to relax that
I could make that random - okay so if I
run that simulator each run of this -
each run generates a different world
right and here I'm showing eight worlds
produced by running a simulator eight
times so sometimes the destination is
closed and the person who just walk in a
straight line otherwise the times I have
to go around the enclosure and sometimes
they're headed into the enclosure but
that we didn't happen to get one of
those simulations here
okay so we've expressed our assumptions
in the form of a simulator a stochastic
simulator so now what procedure can we
use to do inference that uses that
simulator well the one I'm going to show
you is not very efficient and later in
the talk I'll talk more about how to
make these things more efficient but so
what can we do with this simulator well
the most obvious thing we can do is run
it so basically our procedure initially
is going to be to run the simulator over
and over again until we get a virtual
world where the virtual data in that
world is similar to the observed data in
our world and then we're going to return
that virtual world as an explanation so
here's the data and on the right is our
first simulated world so this has the
person walking right but the observed it
has the person walking up so the data
don't match so we're gonna reject that
as an explanation we might get this
simulation run this is a little better
but data still doesn't look quite like
the real data so we're gonna reject this
one - so eventually we'll look might get
a run like this where the person's
headed into the into the box and here
the real data and the virtual data are
kind of similar so we're gonna say okay
that's the next book this could be an
explanation for what we saw and here we
get another one that we reject and here
we're going to accept this one because
again the data are pretty similar and
you might accept this one as well so if
we automated this process we could run
this thing over and over again and
basically accept all these explanations
for which the data are similar and here
I'm showing the destinations being
persistent if if they result in a good
exit if they are going to explain
and this is basically the inferences
that we get at the end so again the
person's probably headed into the
enclosure maybe above the enclosure but
probably not going to the bottom of the
map or the bottom of the scene so if we
run the same algorithm on a different
data set we're gonna get different
inferences so here we've inferred that
the person is probably headed to the
right side of the scene maybe they're
going into the enclosure but probably
with less probability than for the other
data so here's the pseudocode for that
procedure again it works by simulating a
random world until it finds one that
explains the data and then it just
returns that world so also we had to
write this explains data procedure
somehow and I'll come back to that later
and also this procedure each time we
call this it generates one explanation
so we're going to call it over and over
again to get more explanations and this
again this procedure is using two types
of information so first it's using our
assumptions and that takes the form of
running simulator and the second type of
information it takes is using is the
data and that is in the form of this
check that happens here okay and and
this principal combination of these two
and source of information is is one of
the key ideas in probabilistic inference
so we could also apply that procedure to
this to infer the 3d orientation of this
mug so like before we're going to start
by writing a stochastic simulator so
first we're going to assume this is a
mug we could relax that assumption but
for now we're gonna say that's given so
to express that we know it's a mug relie
load a 3d mesh model of a mug and we
don't know the mugs orientation so we're
gonna make that random and we can
express an orientation using three
angles roll pitch and yaw and we're just
going to sample those angles at random
so on the right and visualizing a random
virtual world next the step in our
simulation is going to be to render an
image of what that cup would look like
from that particular perspective and
we're can use for example OpenGL to do
that so we might get the image shown on
the right
and finally we return this virtual world
which has the angles as well as this
resulting image now if we did this over
and over again would you get a bunch of
different virtual worlds so we can run
our procedure again for inference so
given the it on the Left which you're
gonna simulate a bunch of worlds until
we get one where the simulated or
rendered image looks like the real image
so that one doesn't look like it now it
is that one nor that one eventually we
will get one that looks close and here
we find out that okay this mug is
upright and the handle is at a
particular angle now if we kept on
running it eventually we would also
sample this explanation and we'd also
say well this is a valid explanation of
the data so let's accept this too so if
we did this over and over again and
aggregated these results basically we'd
get two types of explanations that we
accept about half of them would be these
upright mugs and half of them will be
these down facing down mugs so there's
one assumption that we might want to
bake in so we know that mugs maybe are
more often to be often facing upright so
how could we give that knowledge to our
system how could we encode that
assumption
well because it's an assumption we're
gonna go back to our simulator so the
yaw and pitch angles if those are zero
then we get an upright mug so we're
gonna actually encode the information
that this mug is usually upright the
mugs are usually upright by biasing the
the sampling process for how we generate
these random angles so now we're going
to more likely generate angles near zero
degrees for these two but we're still
gonna be able to generate a bunch of
other angles too but they're just gonna
be less likely so now if we run our
simulator over and over again we get an
appreciable number of simulations that
have upright mugs in them so if you take
that new simulator plug that into our
procedure for inference we're gonna get
different inferences so now a greater
fraction of the accepted explanations
are going to be upright bugs so you
might be wondering a couple things one
this procedure is pretty inefficient so
as our worlds become more complex the
probability that we
generate a virtual world where the Viet
matches the real that is pretty tiny so
if that's basically guessing check right
and the rest of the talk will be about
using new constructs to improve
efficiency and you also might be
wondering well how do you get realistic
simulators right it can be pretty
complicated so one broad answer is that
they don't need to be realistic as long
as we can admit our ignorant by adding
sufficient randomness into them now a
second idea is that also because these
are simulators written in code hopefully
it becomes easier to illicit domain
expert help to actually express these
assumptions formally as opposed to if
you had to for example write down a
bunch of probability distributions
expressing your assumptions and then
finally we can actually learn pieces of
the model or the pieces of our simulator
from data if we need to so before I move
on to the meat of the talk I'm gonna
talk briefly about the role of
randomness and simulators again so this
is our simulator for the person moving
around in the scene and again the first
randomness was the destination right so
we have to be able to consider all
possible destinations it turns out that
if we fix the destination and the start
point we actually get a lot of different
possible routes so our routing our
router is not a router our route planner
is also random so sometimes it goes
around the left sometimes it goes around
the right and this randomness is
important and intentional because real
people don't always walk the most
efficient route either
so and finally our last piece of
randomness was this random noise we
added to the actual person's location so
these are all possible virtual worlds
here that have the same fixed route so
in all those cases the randomness is
expressing things we we don't know but
there's an interesting side effect of
using randomness in our simulators and
if that allows us to consider pretty
weird and unusual worlds as technically
possible so these are all pretty
reasonable worlds the the person's
location is pretty close to their route
that they were walking along
now here's some other worlds these are
also possible but now the person's
location is a little more dispersed it's
further away from their route so these
are still technically possible and I
don't want to rule them out but they're
less likely so now I'm showing a
sequence of worlds where I'm where the
person's location is gradually being
pulled away from their route and as we
pull these locations further and further
these worlds become less and less likely
actually make a lot less sense right why
is the person walking when they're
rattlers over here so but they're all
technically possible still according to
our assumptions so we're gonna call this
simulator this property of simulators
the stretchiness of a simulator and each
of these worlds is stretching the
simulator to a different degree so as we
stretch it more and more basically these
worlds becoming more unusual and strange
and the simulator is going to be pulling
back with greater and greater force
because it really wants to produce
typical worlds so the stretching is in
our simulator it turns out is going to
help us write more efficient inference
procedures okay so how can we do
inference more efficiently while still
using simulators to express our
assumptions well we're gonna need more
capabilities besides just being able to
run a simulator so for example we would
like a way of measuring quantitatively
how well a given simulated world
explains the data instead of having to
define a very restrictive filter that's
basically going to reject basically all
our most of our simulations so that the
first one is going to be quantifying the
degree of match and we also want to
iteratively improve a simulated world in
order to make it match the data better
that way we can start out with a world
that doesn't match then improve it
gradually instead of having to start
from scratch each time so versions of
the constructs I'm gonna present are
implemented in the gen probabilistic
programming system which is embedded in
Julia and when solving inference problem
in gen the user first begins by writing
a stochastic simulator to express their
assumptions so Jen simulators are like
julia functions but they have a
additional runtime capabilities beyond
regular execution and they have some
additional syntax so we start off with a
julia simulator that we saw before and
to make this into a Jen
we we had this gen annotation in front
to make it a gen function and also we
add annotations in the code for some of
the random choices the simulator is
making and we're using this at trace
expression which is a gen expression and
we're assigning some of these random
choices with a unique ID shown in red
and so these destination IDs are dest x
that's why there's IDs for the actual
location which of these tuples location
1 location 2 and so on so the full set
of ID's that we get for this simulator
is shown on the right in red and I'm
calling this keyword trace because when
Gen execute this code it's going to
record the values of all these random
choices into a sort of execution trace
which is impart a key value store
mapping these IDs to the to the random
values they took in a particular run and
we're actually going to use the
execution trace of the simulator to
represent our virtual world and because
Jan is assembling this data structure
for us we actually don't need to return
this virtual world so I'm just gonna
delete that line so again the execution
traces of these gem functions are going
to be virtual worlds and these are gonna
be the primary data structure that our
inference procedures are going to
manipulate and we're gonna manipulate
those using these IDs as handles to
refer to specific random choices of the
simulator made to control its execution
in different ways ok so now we're ready
for our first new programming construct
so our our first procedure for inference
had two issues right one was that most
simulated worlds didn't match the data
so it would take a long time before it
returned anything and the second was
that the user need to define a condition
to explain the data right there's this
mysterious explained data function so
the first construct which is completing
a partial trace of a gem function
addresses both of these issues so this
function I'm calling complete trace and
it takes a simulator and a partial trace
and the partial trace is just going to
contain the parts of the world that
we've actually observed so in this case
the only thing we observe is the
location so we're passing in this part
specification of a world and we're using
the IDS to refer to those specific
pieces of data and what complete trace
does is it fills in the rest of the
world by selectively running parts of
the simulator so here we'd have to run
all the blue code basically and we
wouldn't need to run this orange line
because that line generated the person's
observed walking location which we were
given so because this world we get is
constructed by fusing together two
different components some of these
resulting worlds are not going to make a
lot of sense so here's a world where the
steps the person takes it's kind of a
little bit off the path or off the route
right so it kind of makes sense but not
that much but we could also have gotten
this world as the output from complete
trace so here it doesn't make any sense
the person's route was going to the
right but they were walking up so and
the length of this pink these pink lines
indicates how much this is sort of
stretching our simulator how much
tension there is in the simulator to
accept this now crucially this cut this
this function complete trace also
returns a score which quantifies
basically how well this world explains
the data and this score quantifies a how
much the world is stretching the
simulator basically so now we can
instead of throwing away all these
simulations we can still use them
because we now we have a quantitative
number for how well they match and Jen
is competing this score automatically
and therefore there's no need for some
heuristic to decide whether the
simulated data matches the real data or
not this is all determined uniquely by
the simulator code okay so now here's a
new inference procedure we can write
using complete trace it takes in the
data and some computation budget end and
it basically is going to complete end
traces or end virtual worlds all
starting with the data as the partial
trace and it stores their the traces and
the scores then it randomly chooses one
of these completed worlds to return they
these scores so a world but the higher
scores can be returned with higher
probability than a rover the lower score
so we're gonna be most likely to return
the one in the middle we might also
return the one on the left with some
probability so I'm like our original
procedure right this procedure
terminates in a fixed and predictable
amount of time because we got to set the
computation budget but it's interesting
to see when N equals 1 our inferences
are about this actually identical to if
we just ran the simulator from scratch
right so here we're not taking the data
into account at all and as we increase n
the inference has become more and more
close to the mathematically correct
definition of Bayesian probabilistic
inference so this procedure is called
important sampling and computational
statistics but with the system like gen
the user does not need to derive custom
equations to compute these scores and
you can implement a generic version of
this procedure in just a couple lines of
giulia code using gen ok so that gave us
a principal procedure for inference with
a predictable running time so that's
some progress but it's still basically
guessing worlds from scratch so the next
construct is going to be about
iteratively improving a trace until it
better and better explains the data so
this we're gonna call improve trace and
that's going to take a simulator a trace
of that simulator this time it's a
complete one and a part of the world to
try to improve and a computation budget
N and it's gonna return a new trace
that's hopefully hopefully makes more
sense and that stretches the simulator
less so here our initial trace might be
on the Left if we decided to improve the
x coordinate of the destination we might
get the new trace on the right so again
here we've kept the y-coordinate fixed
and we just can shift this x-coordinate
over a little bit and we get one that
makes more sense
now this procedure isn't deterministic
because there's lots of other ways to
shift X and still get equally valid
explanations so we could have moved X
into the box
now here's another example suppose we
started with this trace here where you
know the person's route is going to the
right if we're an improve on the
y-coordinate we would be able to move
this up and get an area on the upper
right which makes a lot more sense so we
can use this improved trace construct to
write a third inference procedure and
this one's pretty different than the
other one this one starts with basically
a random world sort of a really well
doesn't make much sense returned by a
complete trace and then it it really
improves the x and y coordinates of the
destination so first we're going to move
the x coordinate left that makes the
world a little better then we're gonna
move the y coordinate up and now we
basically have decent explanations so if
we keep on running this for loop over
and over again we actually start
exploring a space of different worlds
that are all good explanations so
improved world and improved trace
basically has two roles the first one is
to get you from a crazy where that does
make any sense into one that's a good
explanation they can also use it to
explore the space of good explorations
so this approach to in Bayesian
inference is known as Markov chain Monte
Carlo or MC MC and Jan again is
providing users with tools for
implementing MC MC at a pretty high
level of abstraction by automating the
data structures and the derivations of
the probabilistic equations and
numerical calculations and so on okay so
now we've achieved some level of
customization to the problem but there's
lots of things that this framework still
doesn't let us do so what if we for
example have some heuristic that solves
a related problem but that problem isn't
really Bayesian inference or
probabilistic inference or it's not the
same problem so how do we use that with
this simulator based approach so let's
see a toy example so suppose we're
trying to show solve this problem on the
left so we're trying to infer the 3d
orientation of this mug suppose someone
has given you some code which solves
this problem for cylinders because
cylinders are pretty common 3d geometric
from
right so that seems like a related task
since mugs are kind of like cylinders
and suppose this off-the-shelf code was
actually robust enough to work on this
example so it accurately fits a cylinder
to this image and it returns the 3d
orientation of the cylinder so that
would partially solve the problem but
the cylinder detector doesn't know about
handles right so it can't ever figure
out what the angle of the mug is around
its axis and it also doesn't know that
there's an up or down orientation to
these mugs so we can turn that code into
something that solves our problem or at
least has the right type signature by
randomly picking the orientation around
the axis and randomly flipping the mug
upside down but we're gonna keep the
axis fixed to what the heuristic told us
we should so if we ran that including
the random pieces we'd get results to
look something like this
so the top row again contains all these
upward-facing mugs but there's all these
possible rotations of the handle and the
bottom row contains the bottom facing
mugs with all the possible rotations of
a handle also now remember the correct
inference was to have put 90%
probability on upward-facing mugs with
the handle at specific angle
so our heuristic is wrong in two ways so
first it's not taking into account the
existence of the handle right because it
doesn't know about handles but also it's
not taking into account our prior
assumption that upright mugs were more
likely than downward-facing books so we
could try to like mess with our
heuristic and encode get it get it
basically to do that but that could end
up being pretty brittle and our
simulator already has the information we
need encoded in it for to solve both of
these problems so how can we combine the
simulator and the heuristic well is lots
of different ways to do that I'm gonna
show one and we're going to use a
variant of this complete trace construct
that we saw before this variant takes an
extra argument which is going to be the
heuristic and it analyzes the simulator
code and the heuristic code together
they're compatible first then it runs
the heuristic and completes the trace
like we saw before so that again the
heuristic is being used to fill in this
world instead of the simulator now we're
going to return a score like we did
before
and this score is going to quantify how
well the world explains the observed
data and in this case for example this
would allow us to reject the bottom of
the third image the third hypothesis
here so that solves you know the first
problem because we can discard those
those hand those those worlds with the
handle out there at the wrong angle but
this isn't taking into account our
assumption about upright and downward
bugs so this variant of completes trace
actually has a correction term that adds
to the score which accounts for the fact
that the assumptions of the heuristic
were used to generate the explanation
instead of the assumptions of a
simulator so it's going to up wait
worlds where it's facing up and down
where ones where it's facing down and
then we can plug this into another
inference procedure which is basically
just like the infer - procedure but now
it uses the heuristic and if we run this
with enough computation budget we should
get the right answer - so now let's see
qualitatively how this heuristic is is
helping us so first let's consider this
inference procedure we saw before infer
- that did not use the heuristic so with
the computation budget of 1 + equals 1
we get pretty low accuracy in fact it's
just behaving like a simulator itself so
it's just reflecting our prior
assumptions so these are just all the
random orientations we can imagine again
as we increase n even without the
heuristic as we increase n we approach
the optimal Bayesian inference and in
blue I'm showing the behavior of our new
procedure infer for which uses the
heuristic so when this procedure is run
with N equals 1 it actually behaves just
like the heuristic so hopefully the
heuristic is more accurate than our
prior assumptions because it's taking
the data into account but it also might
be wrong in all sorts of ways like we
saw
but as we increase the computation
budget on this new procedure we actually
also approach the same inferences as we
did originally so we're going to get the
correct Bayesian inference and we're
going to be able to do that with less
computation cost okay so our final
construct is going to allow us to learn
good heuristics in a principled way
automatically using training data
generated by the simulator and in
particular that's going to allow us to
use things like deep neural networks in
our heuristics so here's an example
suppose we have a single error for
silhouettes of a human body on the right
and the way the simulator works at first
generating some joint angles then using
some computer graphics techniques to
generate our mesh then rendering that
into the silhouette image on the right
and some of the random poses this this
can generate are shown on the bottom now
we can generate synthetic examples by
running this simulator over and over
again and then train the deep neural
network to predict the joint angles from
the silhouette and Jen is going to give
us the loss function we need
automatically just to do this training
in a principled way so if we just run
the resulting trained heuristic based on
the neural network we'll get something
that kind of works but in this case it
has lingering uncertainty about the
elbow angle if we add this here is take
into our infer for inference procedure
we can actually resolve that ambiguity
and the way that works is we're actually
rendering each of these poses proposed
by the neural network through OpenGL and
checking whether the resulting data
actually matches the observed data so
this is one example of how deep learning
and the simulator approach to inference
complimentary so I just gave the
perspective from simulator based
inference where we're using deep
learning to make it more efficient by
amortize in the cost of training the
deep neural network across many problem
instances or many inference problems but
we can also take the perspective of
someone who works in deep learning and
so recently in deep learning has become
more popular to use simulated and
synthetic data for domains where it's
really hard to achieve
lots of hand labelled data but here
we're actually using simulators at
entrance time also and not just offline
for training data and the reason why
that's less done is because to do that
you really need to write your simulators
in a language like this with these new
programming constructs and with those
new constructs which you know in
languages like Gen we're able to improve
the robustness of deep learning so some
ongoing projects we have that are using
this approach and using gen include 3d
scene understanding audio scene analysis
causal inference and oral collaborators
are also applying gen to data science
tasks like probabilistic cleaning and
imputation for data tables and Alex leva
is actually giving a talk on that
tomorrow that I recommend you attend
that's all thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah yeah so the question is you know
it's pretty obvious that we can use
physics to avoid physically impossible
worlds when you want to make their your
simulator more accurate more physically
realistic so yeah I think that's this
question of you can always make your
simulators more realistic that does make
them more complex so what one degree is
a complexity of implementation versus
you know what it's giving in terms are
accuracy so I agree that yeah you get
more accurate inferences but it might be
more complex to implement and the
running time would be higher so that's
sort of the trade-off that's I think the
primary trade-off is we want to provide
a design space where you can implement
pretty simple things that are kind of
stupid they're kind of dumb right but
they're really easy to implement and
maybe they're dumb in ways that aren't
catastrophic so if we implement a
simulator that is ignorant of physical
laws but we add enough randomness to
express that then it's just gonna be
uncertain to uncertain right it's not
going to necessarily be overconfident
that's I think a sort of graceful decay
and performance direction so that's yeah
yeah so for that I was using the some of
the of the distances between the data
points that correspond 'add so so no so
that I was implementing that in a very
beginning as part of our heuristic
procedure for checking whether the data
matches but the actual score it's it's
not exactly doing that but actually it
turns out so it's doing basically it's
computing a probability of how probable
is this virtual data or how probable is
the real data given the rest of the
trace and it turns out that that
probability is basically proportion or
the log probabilities proportional to
that that's sum of distances in that
case so it's basically the tuition is
the same but the thing is that the
system is computing that for us using
the the randomness and the probabilistic
semantics of the simulator instead of us
having to derive that as a it's a manual
heuristic yes
yeah so the question is how you decide a
threshold on was it
I'm was a good explanation of data or or
though okay so I think so right in the
beginning you could set an arbitrary
threshold in the first part of the talk
the second part of the talk says that
basically that that score
there's no threshold there's no hard
threshold that is involved so really
that quantitative metric of how close to
this is being determined uniquely by the
simulator so you can modulate this
quantity by changing the randomness in
your simulator so for example if you had
a simulator where I made these these
these locations random very random right
like the blue X's would be all over the
place then I would be more willing to
accept worlds where the blue X's don't
match though throughout so it's
basically the emissive it's an important
degree of freedom which is in part
modulating the trade-off between
computational difficulty of this problem
and how confident you can be right so
that that procedure is void studying a
threshold exactly yeah and it does have
a computation budget right so the more
you run it the results do change but yes
right yeah exactly so so particularly
for graphics that's really hard problem
and yeah so so one thing we can do is
and we're doing this in some of our
other projects instead of using the
literal image instead of basically
trying to simulate a photorealistic
image right which is gonna be super
complicated there's all these things you
can't take into account a necessarily
we're going to only simulate some
simplified version of the data and then
so for an example is if we can get to go
from our real image to something that
just is a depth image right then we can
simulate realistic depth images a lot
more than we can simulate realistic
photos right so basically we can always
try to take move from this original data
space into some simplified form of it
applied some pre-processing and try to
take our way of some of these nuisance
variables like the lighting for example
so another example that people have
applied for images is is basically
running a edge detector on the image
because edges are going to be you know
edge the edge image is a little more
invariant to some of these things than
the actual image itself in the original
image right
right so I think one thing we're we're
trying to do is build reusable
components so because so graphics
rendering right is a reusable piece we
can use that in many many different
projects so if we can figure out how to
do it for graphics then that'll not so
like a reusable code and that this also
is one of the reasons why we want to use
code to represent our simulators right
because we can use code we can just make
function calls to a graphics library
right so we can reuse pieces so
basically figuring this out for four
images is a research problem as
continuing to be worked on yeah yes so
that's what I happen to be focused on
right now I think yeah basically I think
the that the underlying technique can be
applied to all sorts of other areas too
yeah we can I think there's a really
interesting question I'd like to talk
more about that actually fun but it
sounds really complicated we should get
it to it yes
yes the question is do we use clustering
algorithms to determine the amount of
randomness to use so I think one so one
thing we can do is we can try to learn
the amount of randomness that we need oh
I see okay yeah that's interesting yeah
so there are like adaptive versions of
these techniques where instead of just
like for the improved world for loop
right you can make these things adaptive
so they have some memory so yeah there
aren't there's like whole space of
elaborate procedures there and the idea
is that system like this because there's
a pretty low level constructs you can
still explore that space of interesting
things okay I think I'll take the rest
offline Thanks